today on the matt walsh show the left is
now pushing hard for
reparations for slavery we'll talk about
all the reasons why that's a terrible
idea also
five headlines including tucker
carlson's urgent and important warning
to the president
and in our daily cancellation i will be
canceling canceling the song
imagine before it becomes
our new national anthem god help us all
that's what they're talking about doing
next
and we'll get to all of that coming up
but before we do today's show brought to
you by
ancestrydna you know it's uh it's just
fascinating and i think fulfilling in a
lot of very deep ways to learn
about your ancestry that's how it was
for me you know going through the
ancestry.com experience
was a lot of fun very easy and
to discover my own ancestry laid out
before me was
just completely fascinating yeah you may
be familiar with the major events and
battles of world war
ii but there are so many more stories to
uncover uh the skill and
bravery of the tuskegee airmen and all
african-american
squad of fighter pilots the incredible
women who trained to become pilots and
mechanics the japanese-american
battalion
uh became one of america's most
decorated units in honor of the 75th
anniversary of the end of world war ii
ancestry has just released a us draft
card collection from world war
ii over 36 million draft cards completed
by fighting age men in the united states
across the country during that time
and you get a chance to take a look and
you can uncover your ancestors personal
details
in uh in ancestry uh world war ii
u.s draft card collection which shows
details like home address physical
description
much much more uh you could find the
veterans in your family who rose to the
occasion where the world needed the most
and uh you know gives you pride even
though
it was a long time ago these are your
ancestors and there's a lot of pride in
that discover your untold stories and
more head to my url at ancestry.com
matt to start discovering your story
today that's ancestry.com
met all right well an idea that was once
on the fringe of the fringe of the
fringe is now surging into the
mainstream and make no mistake if
democrats
uh are to take over on election day
which might well happen
this will be enacted without a doubt
they will do it unlike republicans
democrats
they actually set out to accomplish
their goals
and the promises they make to their
voters they actually try to make them
happen
even if the promises are horrific the
idea is
reparations paying black americans for
slavery
uh paying them back for the injustices
perpetrated injustices perpetrated
against their ancestors
this idea was discussed during the
democrat primary as you may remember
and every candidate to my memory came
out in support of it
now it's back in the news again back in
the discussion again the new york times
magazine ran a lengthy piece titled
what is owed makes the case for
reparations
and it's been discussed in the
mainstream media regularly there was a
segment on it on msnbc this morning
here's a segment on on nbc um actually
their streaming service
i believe referring to the times piece
explaining why
reparations should happen centuries of
systemic racism have created
a wealth gap in america between black
and white americans
in her latest new york times piece
pulitzer prize-winning reporter nicole
hannah jones writes
if true justice and equality are ever to
be achieved in the united states
the country must finally take seriously
what it owes black americans
msnbc correspondent tremaine lee
interviewed nicole hannah jones in his
latest into america podcast on
reparations
tremaine joins me now and truman what
are the factors that nicole talked about
here that are contributing or have
contributed
to the racial wealth gap in our country
hey allison more than just a
contribution
the actual source the root of the wealth
gap goes back to shortly after
emancipation
uh when the entire uh you know enslaved
population formerly enslaved population
uh really were pushed out with
absolutely nothing starting from ground
zero
and even though the government had
promised some uh restitution in 40 acres
and a mule
those promises fell through and in fact
the the former um
you know plantation owners were given
back that land that had been promised to
enslave people but then after that
decades and decades of jim crow laws
lack of access to
jobs uh depressed housing um values
on and on up from after emancipation
through reconstruction redemption
into the 50s and 60s all of these
contributing factors i'm including the
actual
violent dispossession of wealth the
actual bombing of black wall street the
actual
uh burning and looting of black
communities all across the country
and that land and that wealth and
resources were never returned
okay now here's a professor at duke
explaining on the outlet aj plus
whatever that is that reparations is the
way to close the racial
wealth gap the racial wealth gap is
as you know is staggering blacks are
about 13 percent of the u.s population
but only have 2.6 of the nation's wealth
and that translates into an average
household differential
between blacks and whites in net worth
of about eight hundred thousand dollars
in 2016
that's the gap that needs to be that
needs to be closed
by a reparations program but how would
this all be funded well the professor
has an answer
for that too in
the book that i've just completed with
kirsten mullen from here to equality
reparations for black americans in the
21st century
we argue that the payments might be made
in the form
of endowments or a trust account where
individuals be allowed to spend
the interest off the account in any
given year
but could only dip into the principles
subject to approval
for a plan of action
or proposal that they develop
[Music]
in the present moment you know the
federal government overnight
essentially came up with well some
people say it's
2.2 trillion dollars some people say
it's as much as 6 trillion because of
the loans that were made
by the federal reserve board but came up
with that money overnight there were no
new taxes administered
and i think that the present experience
or the current experience
demonstrates that the federal government
can spend on virtually anything it wants
to spend on
so his plan is apparently to just come
up with the money
that's his plan just you know come up
with the money all right then
an article on cnn published a while ago
says a little while ago back back during
the primaries
gets slightly more specific it says
generally advocates for operations say
that three different groups should pay
for them
governments private companies and rich
families that owe a good portion of
their wealth
to slavery it then goes on to explain
that at least for the rich families
you'd probably have to extract that
money through litigation rather than
legislation
so between rich families companies and
governments which are funded by everyone
this basically means that
everyone will have to pay at some level
in some form
for reparations and of course i say that
with democrats in power this is going to
happen
which will but really even with
republicans it will happen too
eventually
we're not far away from this becoming um
an idea that republicans are even
presenting now they'll present it in a
in a s in a slightly more moderated way
they'll have a reformed idea of
reparations
but they're going to start proposing
this too because we know the trajectory
this is the trajectory with everything
an idea
is on the fringes of the left wing then
it becomes mainstream
then a few years later it becomes
mainstream among republican circles
republicans are on the same track and
train as the democrats
are just a few cars back so
which is why when you look at so many of
the positions taken by republicans today
those are the same positions that um
democrats took you know back in the 90s
so this may be inevitable but even so
it's worth discussing what are the
problems with this idea
there are many problems let's discuss a
few of them first of all this may be the
most crucial point
the idea that the racial wealth gap is
the main driver
um or that slavery is the main driver of
the racial wealth gap that's something
that needs to be addressed
because the racial wealth gap is itself
probably the main driver of the push for
reparations
uh it's argued that collectively black
americans are poorer than white
americans and it's
further argued that this is due to
slavery and segregation
now the first part of that argument is
true that's just a statistical reality
no getting around it
what about blaming it on slavery and
racism though
there's no doubt that history has an
impact on everything in the present
including economics and wealth
distribution so no serious person
would say that slavery has no effect on
what's happening today
everything in history has some effect um
but there are things happening today
also that are going to have a much much
greater
impact on the wealth impact on the
wealth
gap i should say and i'll give you just
one the fatherless rate black
fatherlessness is about 70
that is 70 of black children today
grow up in a household with a single
parent their parents are not married
and their dad doesn't live with them
studies have repeatedly and decisively
shown
that fatherlessness is a major
contributor to poverty
the dropout rate the incarceration rate
crime
drug abuse suicide and so on
pretty much every social ill you can
name
uh is tied to fatherlessness in some way
fatherlessness is going to be a a
significant
contributing factor to it so the point
is that
even if you make some sort of payment to
black americans
no matter how large that payment is it's
not going to fix
fatherlessness and so it's not going to
fix anything
really economically or socially or in
any other way
until we've addressed things like this
um there's there's not a lot of progress
that can be made especially by just
giving money to people
second point um
in fact before we get to the second
point we'll do that in just a second
but first i want to tell you about our
friends at policy genius
you know life insurance um makes
a lot of sense because the only thing
you have to know with life insurance is
that you're not you're not immortal
you're not going to be here forever
you're going to die one day i i hate to
tell you that's that's the bad news
and with everything going on right now a
lot of people are asking if it's even
possible to buy life insurance at all
and the answer is
yes the answer number one is yes you
need it and number two
yes you can buy it you can buy life
insurance during a pandemic you can you
can certainly buy life insurance if you
have loved ones depending on your income
you probably should as an insurance
marketplace policy genius is in contact
with the life insurance companies on
their platform every day
they're keeping track of all the changes
in the market so you don't have to
which means they can get you covered
quickly and for the best price here's
how it works policy genius compares
quotes from the top
life insurance companies in one place it
takes just a few minutes to compare
quotes from top insurers to find your
best price
this doesn't take um you know a lot of
work on your part it saves you a lot of
legwork
policy genius is doing almost all the
work for you and you could save 1500
or more a year by you using like policy
genius to compare life insurance
policies so you're saving money you're
saving time you're saving the
frustration
uh it's just there's no reason not to do
it getting life insurance i think is a
moral obligation of all people
you know when you have a family to make
sure they're taken care of and if you're
going to do it policy genius is the way
to go so if you're one of the many
people looking to buy life insurance
right now
but you're not sure where to start well
head to policygenius.com policy genius
will find the best rate handle the
process completely
they'll get you and your family
protected and hopefully give you one
less thing to worry about which is
something we could all use now
okay second point on reparations the
reparations concept really demonstrates
just how simplistic
and binary and literally black and white
our thinking has become
black people were enslaved white people
were slave owners
therefore white people should pay black
people that's
that's the thought process even leaving
aside
how long ago this was and the fact that
as already explained
other social factors are doing much more
today to hold the black community back
leaving those things aside this assumes
that
every black person is a descendant of of
american slaves
and every white person is a descendant
of
slave owners in america it also assumes
that
if historical injustice should mean
present day reparations
only black people have suffered
injustice that needs to be repaired
all of that is wrong a great many black
americans today
millions came here um or
are are descendants of people who came
here after
often well after the end of slavery and
even after the end of segregation
um you know let's say a black person
whose parents came to this country in
1975
would they get reparations
meanwhile most white people and their
lineage never had anything to do with
slavery in america and that was true
even when slavery was ongoing in 1860 a
small minority of americans countrywide
owned slaves
depending on where you look you know it
was something like five to ten percent
certainly minority country-wide even in
the south a minority
so if we were doing reparations
right after slavery was abolished
which if it was going to happen that was
when it should have happened
but but even then um
you would have been talking about a
minority of americans
who should have paid because they were
the ones who owned slaves
and they were the ones who immediately
benefited from slave labor
now tack 150 years on to it and and take
into account all the many millions of
americans
who came to this country sometime in the
intervening period
it would make no sense whatsoever for a
person whose ancestors came here from
poland
or italy or whatever a few decades ago
to be forced to pay for crimes that were
committed a century and a half ago
thousands of miles from where that
person's ancestors actually lived
and the only reason they're being told
to pay it is because of the the pigment
of their skin
this is unjust it's not it's not paying
for the crimes of your ancestors which
already is unjust i would argue but this
time you're paying for the crimes of
other people's ancestors that you had
nothing to do with and your ancestors
had nothing to do with
moreover more moreover we aren't taking
into account
the persecution and oppression faced by
many other groups of people
should a jewish person whose
grandparents fled the holocaust in 1940
and came here and faced anti-semitism
should they have to pay for the
persecution carried out by other people
against other people why
and if we want to talk about the legacy
of an atrocity and how it negatively
affects people today could not that
jewish person argue that they
would be in a much better spot today if
not for the fact that half of their
lineage was wiped out in a concentration
camp
i think they could argue that what about
an irish person whose family escaped the
potato famine which killed a million
people in about four or five years
came to america face segregation
discrimination ethnocentrism
all targeted against them signs hanging
in businesses saying no dogs no irish or
irish need not apply
this is a person who also if not for
those forms of historical oppression
may be in a better place today and yet
they would be made to pay
but doesn't society owe them to on the
reparations theory doesn't society also
owe them
something now maybe you would say
doesn't own as much as it owes black
people but it owes them something
doesn't it
so should we be talking about
reparations on a spectrum where everyone
who's an ancestor of a persecuted
minority
is is given something
you see that's that's the other problem
once you go down this road
there's no limiting principle pay
reparations to black
people then it's hard to argue at that
point that you don't pay to native
americans
in fact i would i would assume most of
the people who support reparations
for black americans would would probably
say yes let's give it to native
americans too
um so okay well then you've got those
groups what about asian americans who
are sent to internment camps
or other groups of americans who face
segregation and discrimination
and on and on you go now again you could
argue
that that some of those groups are owed
less than others
however you measure this which it seems
impossible to measure and quantify but
however you do it
you you could find a way of of
staggering it and
and uh as i said put it on a spectrum
but the principle that justifies
payment of some kind to one group also
justifies
payment of some kind to others
and then you get to a point very quickly
where almost everyone in america is owed
reparations
for something and
the whole idea breaks down so
it just it's a it's a
a concept that makes no sense it would
only increase
injustice it certainly wouldn't remedy
it
and that's why it's an idea that we need
to meet forcefully
but i'll tell you exactly what's going
to happen what's happening right now
is that a lot of people on the right
aren't even bothering to argue the point
because they figure they're making the
same mistake they always make with
everything
thinking that this is a fringe thing
it's not going to happen no one you know
no one really takes it seriously we're
not really going to do this
no it's not fringe they really want to
do it and they will do it
especially if we don't say anything
about it
let's move on to news headlines speaking
of things that need to be said
number one tucker carlson who i think is
one of the most important voices in
america right now
had an excellent monologue last night
and his message
needs to be heard loud and clear
particularly by one person who hopefully
was watching
it would change the course of this
country's future
if the justice department rounded up the
leaders of antifa tomorrow
along with every single person caught on
camera torching a building
destroying a monument defacing a church
and put them all in shackles
and then frog marched them in front of
cameras like ms-13
and called them what they actually are
domestic terrorists
not protesters not civil rights
activists not cnn contributors
but domestic terrorists that would be
their new
government approved title once they're
charged it's official
in fact they are literally as a factual
matter accused terrorists
and that would change minds right away
most people don't like terrorists
terrorists will never be popular even
among democratic voters
so charge them for the crimes they've
committed and call them what they are
right now the opposite is happening the
terrorists are more popular than the
president of the united states
and not just more popular than donald
trump personally but more
popular than the system he represents
and administers
and it's obvious why our system is weak
it refuses to defend itself mayors let
new countries
sprout in the middle of their cities our
leaders act like laws
are irrelevant everyone watches this
happen
it's a potentially fatal problem weak
institutions
die citizens develop contempt for them
and then they get overthrown
the same is true by the way for heads of
state when you refuse to fight for the
system you run
you're done spend an hour on google and
see if you can find a single leader in
the history of the world
who stayed in power after failing to
quell a rebellion
you can't by the way that clip was
shared by a media matters person calling
it
maybe the most deranged rant i've heard
on fox news
meanwhile he said that was deranged
meanwhile
all normal people think it's one of the
sanest things we've ever heard
or at least recently heard tucker is
exactly right
and if anyone needs to hear him loud and
clear it's primarily the president
now i know some of you don't like it
when i criticize them i know that
that's fine you don't have to like it
but i'm telling you the fact of the
matter
tucker's saying the fact of the matter
like it or not trump is losing right now
i'm not just talking about the polls and
the polls are one indicator
but it's not just about that i don't
need i don't even need to see the polls
i don't care what the polls say
trump is losing right now make all the
lame excuses you want
but if trump continues tweeting while
america burns
he will lose more than that he will
deserve to lose
it's better for a supporter saying to
face this fact now put some pressure on
him
than to whisper sweet nothings in his
ear telling him that that the law and
order tweets are
are great and totally sufficient
everyone loves it he's doing great
nothing is wrong
they aren't sufficient everyone doesn't
love it and shouldn't
okay the tweeting in general i think
most people i get it again you're
if you're a die-hard you know fan
then uh then you're always going to love
the tweets but most people are not die
hard fans and never were
trump won 2016 with 70 000 votes
that gave him the the electoral college
victory while losing the popular vote by
2 million votes
this is a he won by a hair's breadth
so i mean his his supporters have been
lying to him he's been lying to himself
since day one
saying that it was some sort of land
size slide victory not even close
um this needs to be communicated to
trump in a hurry
because right now it's like the guy
isn't even trying
he did a town hall on fox last night i
don't know if you watched this thing
and he was asked uh what his plan is for
a second term now
he's asked by sean hannity you could ask
for a friendlier interviewer
and you can ask for an easier question
what's your plan for the second term you
you gotta have an answer to that that's
that's your president you're an
incumbent president running for a second
term
somebody asks you what's your plan for a
second term you should be boom boom boom
boom have answers
this is what trump said let's talk about
a second term
if you hear in 131 days from now at some
point in the night or
early morning we can now project donald
j
trump has been re-elected the 45th
president of the united states let's
talk how do
what's at stake in this election as you
compare and contrast
and what is what are your top priority
items for a second term well one of the
things that will
be really great you know the word
experience is still good i always say
talent is more
important than experience i've always
said that but the word experience
is a very important word it's in a very
important meeting
i never did this before i never slept
over in washington i was in washington i
think 17 times all of a sudden i'm
president of the united states you know
the story of riding down
pennsylvania avenue with our first lady
and i say this is great
but i didn't know very many people in
washington it wasn't my thing i was from
manhattan from new york
now i know everybody and i have great
people in the administration
you make some mistakes like you know an
idiot like bolton all you want to do is
drop bombs on everybody you don't have
to drop bombs on everybody you have to
kill people
that's just nonsense that's that's
i don't want to hear uh it's trump being
trump i don't give a damn if it's trump
being trump trump needs to stop being
trump
that's babbling ridiculous nonsense you
were asked a question
what's your plan people actually want to
hear it
it's a good question that was not an
answer
if the guy can't even tell us what he
wants what he wants to do in a second
term
why should anyone vote for him he
literally can't give you a reason to
vote for him
other than joe biden blah blah blah
that's not going to be enough
it was enough against hillary okay to
beat hillary all you had to do was say
look at hillary hillary hillary hillary
i think this time around when you're in
the incumbent and you have a record for
better or worse
you need to actually present a positive
reason to vote for you
for you what is good about you
now this excuse that people are
providing for trump that is that his
supporters are providing
trump is doing nothing as anarchists
uh destroyed the country the excuse is
well we'll let the let the leftist
cities destroy themselves
no yeah that might seem like the sort of
tough
uh approach it's not tough it's weak and
cowardly
it's the weakest bs i've ever heard
what you're saying is let's give the
criminals and anarchists everything they
want
that'll show them so what you're doing
if you
let them destroy themselves no it's not
them destroying themselves
it's allowing criminals and anarchists
to do what they want
while innocent americans in those cities
suffer
trump is the president of those people
and it's not and and you and if your
next if your next move is to blame them
for living in the city to begin with
that's not going to be a winning message
wow they deserve it
they made a choice to live in a city
because that's where they found a job
you might be able to soothe yourself
with that message that is not a winning
message
trump is the president of those people
he's their president too
you're not punishing the anarchists
by letting them do what they want is is
this what people do with their kids i i
guess yeah this
explains a lot really this is how a lot
of parents act with their kids
i'll show them by letting them stay up
all night playing playstation
they'll learn their lesson eventually
yeah maybe maybe 30 years from now when
they look back at their wasted childhood
that's when they'll learn their lesson
that's not good enough no they need to
learn their lesson now you're the parent
do it
now i certainly hate to compare a
politician to a parent because that's
not the relationship politics is
supposed to have with the public but
still
these people are acting like children
and worse
that's an insult to children they're
acting like worse than children
and they do need to be punished law and
order not just a tweet
he's floundering it's pathetic he's
gonna lose
that's the reality if he doesn't do
something
now number two they're coming for mount
rushmore uh now
a report from daily wire says on
thursday usa today
quoted that a tribal leader of the sioux
nation saying that
although mount rushmore should not be
blown up it should be removed
how do you remove a mountain i don't
know
um oglala sioux president julian bear
runner who expressed his disapproval of
president trump's visit next week to the
black hills south dakota state of mount
rushmore
i don't believe it should be blown up
because it would cause more damage to
the land
but he agrees that it should be removed
and then there's a lot of stuff about
how this is a symbol of
nick tilson of the oglala lakota tribe
said rush mount rushmore is a symbol of
white supremacy of structural racism
that's still alive and well in society
today
and on and on and they'll do it they'll
do it too
they'll do anything they want okay
the people that are seeking to tear down
the monuments and tear down western
civilization
and all of its icons and heroes they're
just getting whatever they want
and that how that's how we're again that
that's how we're
we're punishing them by just letting
them do it
great strategy wonderful
number three here's something to think
about uh next time you're at the beach
look at this drone footage of a great
white shark gigantic beast
swimming right under unsuspecting
surfers
good god almighty now you know
i like the beach i love the water but it
is kind of a weird thing we do isn't it
i always think
if aliens were to come to this country
they would be that'd be one of the many
things they're very surprised and
confused by
they would say why are these humans
gathered around and for no constructive
reason
swimming and paddling in this giant
salty death trap where man-eating
monsters are lurking in the deaths
and a lot of them aren't even doing
anything and if you go to a beach
they're just
standing in it letting the the ferocious
waves pummel them in the face
while they get sand up their shorts and
they do that for an hour and a half and
then they go home what was the point of
this ritual that's what the aliens would
be asking
i imagine of course i'm also assuming
that aliens don't know what an ocean is
and if they didn't have an ocean on
their home planet there would be no
civilization to begin with so you know
there are problems with my hypothetical
but anyway
number four after 30 years the dixie
chicks are changing their name
uh they will now be the chicks not the
dixie chicks
[Music]
why is the word dixie offensive this is
this is uh
very interesting a lot of ways and it
shows among other things
what i'm always talking about how
feminists
are constantly having to take a back
seat on the when it comes on the modern
left
feminists are very close to the bottom
of the totem pole they're
they're almost at this point they're
treated almost like
white men to be a feminist you're you're
you're very you're not that much you're
not that
that uh that much higher
you know on the hierarchy than white men
are as feminists
uh because all of their interests are
thrown to the side and you see here
so dixie chicks changing their name and
they're going to keep one of the words
they decide to keep
chicks which the feminists have been
saying for decades
is offensive and now they're just the
chicks
we've got to get rid of dixie but not
chicks
i just think that's very emblematic of
the situation on the modern left
uh and of course meanwhile
you've been the dixie chicks for 30
years you're just now deciding that it's
offensive after three decades
what changed your mind what made you
realize that it's offensive
what were you told in the last year
or few months really that you didn't
know already
that made you decide that it's offensive
now it's not offensive the word dixie is
not at all offensive
but if you think that it is what new
information were you provided
that brought you to this conclusion or
have you thought that it was a racist
name all along and you did
and so you've just been white
supremacists for 30 years
which is it dixie chicks
i didn't even know the dick chicks still
it still still existed to be honest i
had no idea that they were still
out there making music all right number
five a report from
fox carolina a very
sad disturbing infuriating story the
forest city
department police department said a
young girl has died after she was
severely injured in a shooting on
tuesday evening the shooting happened
along the intersection of oak street and
harmon street around 5 pm
the officers arrived found two
individuals pulling a seven-year-old
girl
from a vehicle
and she was suffering a single gunshot
wound to the head
now they arrested uh shaquille marshawn
francis 26 years old
charging him with shooting this girl in
the head
they haven't been there's there's no
information about motive or anything
not that motive matters at all with a
crime like this
um but here's the thing
francis uh the monstrous scumbag or
alleged monstrous scumbag
was released from jail just a few hours
before
one of the reports i read said he was
released from jail on different charges
other charges
i think it was an assault by pointing a
gun at someone
he was one report said three hours
earlier he was released
and then allegedly immediately went
and shot a girl in the head this goes
back to what i've been the drum i've
been banging
for weeks now that if we're going to be
doing reforms
um reforms that protect black lives and
all lives
then rather than police reform being the
first thing we do
we should be looking at reforms that
would prevent
murderous sociopaths from walking the
streets
because the current strategy is that
criminals dangerous criminals
get out of jail a million times until
they do something
so unbelievably heinous that
there's no choice but to lock them away
for
and even then a lot of times it's not
forever it's for you know but at least
for
many years that's the strategy right now
i mean you have someone who you just you
know if they've committed many
crimes many of them violent and you you
just you know that eventually they're
going to do something
utterly horrible and but all we do is
just wait for them to do that thing
and to that victim even if it's a
seven-year-old girl apparently the
system is saying well you know
too bad basically is what is what the
system is saying to these victims
i i think this should be the reform
you know if you have someone if this is
the crime that he committed
assault with a deadly weapon before what
is he doing back out on the street
keep him in jail this is a dangerous
person
why are you letting them out
that should be our reform all right
we're going to move on to our daily
cancellation
uh by the way if you haven't gotten the
daily wire reader pass yet you should
definitely do if you're not a daily wire
member
and you're looking to read some of our
great content um go get a daily wire
reader pass you can get it for just the
first month just a dollar
actually 99 cents so you save even an
extra penny
which is good and if you get a reader
pass now i mean my latest article
talking about
um the the you know the left's message
now that it's simply not okay
for actors to pretend to be something
they're not
and i was talking about the case kristen
bell and jenny slate two actresses that
decided to stop
voicing uh cartoon characters who were
not white
now of course cartoon characters aren't
white or black or any cartoon characters
don't have a race because they're
cartoon characters but
that's what we're being told now you
just even in the in the context of an
animated cartoon
you can't pretend to be something you're
not and uh so i'm talking about that in
that article you can go read it now
okay for the daily cancellation i'm
gonna be canceling one of the worst
songs
ever written a song that has been the
bane of my existence
a blight on our society and a scourge on
the earth for decades
that's john lennon's imagine and i'm
canceling it because for one thing it's
just a
terrible song though gets credit for
being one of the great songs ever
written
so that's one reason two i'm canceling
it in a pre-emptive strike this is a
strategic pre-emptive cancellation
because activists are now talking about
making it our new national anthem
not a joke well it is a joke but not an
intentional one
an article in yahoo titled why it might
be time to finally replace the
star-spangled banner
with a new national anthem it makes the
case that we have to get rid of the song
because apparently you won't believe
this francis scott key who wrote the
song
and was born 250 years ago had some
problematic
views on race crazy
you know of course 250 years ago all
people had problematic views on race
but we're going to hold them accountable
now for the crime of being born in the
wrong century
that you know francis scott key and all
these other people
they should have made a more virtuous
choice in what century they were born in
and that's that's their fault we're
gonna hold him accountable for it
tear down the statues francis scott key
had a statute torn down
and i think it was san francisco this
week and now they're gonna get rid of
the song too
and yeah that's that they deserve it i
guess because of that because
they they should have thought better
about what century they were born in
they should in utero they should have
said to their mom hey
hey mom what century is it oh it's uh
it's the
it's the it's the uh the 18th century oh
you know what
i i don't want to be born yet let's
let's check back in the
you know 20th 21st
um there are a few suggestions of what
to replace it with but
imagine is a popular one
one activist explains that imagine is
quote the most beautiful unifying all
people
all backgrounds together kind of song
you can have
is it though here are the lyrics i mean
we all know the lyrics but just just
when you have just the lyrics okay and
john john lennon is supposed to be a
great
songwriter a poet right
imagine there's no countries it isn't
hard to do nothing to kill or die for
and no religion too
imagine all the people living life in
peace you may say i'm a dreamer but i'm
not the only one
i hope someday you'll join us and the
world will be as one
imagine no possessions i wonder if you
can no need for greed or hunger
the brotherhood of man imagine all the
people
sharing all the world the this is
uh now first of all the idea of
destroying all religions and countries
isn't very unifying to people who have a
religion
and love their country but second this
is just this is like something a sixth
grader would write
if he was given an assignment to write
some sort of profound
socially conscious song that's what a
sixth grader would come up with
if i was the teacher i would give it a c
minus at best
imagine there's no greed or hunger but
yeah but
well i'm glad i i listened to imagine
because before i did
it never occurred to me that it would be
better if there was no greed or hunger i
never i never thought i was i was
actually more in the pro-greed in hunger
camp
i was very pro-hunger really and then i
heard
john lennon's song and i thought you
know he really makes a good point
maybe better off without greed and
hunger
wow now you know i could right now
come up with additional verses off the
top of my head
that would be at least as good as what's
in that song
and in fact i'll do it and because you
know if this is going to be our new
national anthem it needs to be a little
bit longer that's one problem
it's a little short so let me suggest
you didn't know that i'm a poet too i'm
a poet i am as good a poet as john
lennon
and i'll prove it too let me suggest a
couple of additional verses for
uh john i'm not going to sing them but
i'll spoken word poetry so you can
really absorb
the impact of these words imagine only
good stuff happening
and really good stuff too
no bad stuff no sad stuff
and no mad stuff too
imagine everyone's happy and they're
being real nice
no one's being super mean
and there are no fights
that's that's two two verses right there
boom just like that
i just wrote half of a classic all-time
great
song just right right there on this
podcast
you didn't you didn't know you'd be
witnessing that um
and i don't know that's something
that's just something from my heart okay
that's where my heart is right now
you know listening to the song i thought
he covered a lot of stuff that we
shouldn't have like greed and hunger
but i'm thinking all the bad stuff you
know
let's not let's not focus on this bad
thing or that
let's get rid of all the bad stuff even
more than that
let's start thinking about what if
everyone is just happy all the time
wow pretty mind-blowing i know um
but even so uh john the the song imagine
is canceled and all efforts to replace
the national anthem
are also cancelled but i would warn
again that all of
all of this we can make jokes about it
because sometimes you think what else
can we do
um especially when the people that we've
elected to do things about it are doing
nothing
but we should remember that that that
all of this
this is serious on the left this is
really what they want to do
and they will do it if nobody prevents
it
if nobody steps in in the path all of
it's happening
you think replacing the national anthem
with imagine is some outlandish
crazy idea it is but you think that's
gonna
prevent it from actually happening no
not at all and on that bright note we
will leave
and end it for the week have a great
weekend everybody
enjoy yourselves godspeed
the matt wall show was produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt walsh show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle
we'll tune in to the ben shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more
see you there